and finally new rule you can't spend the
first half of a debate bitching about
how immigrants are ruining the country
and the second half on the uplifting
stories of your immigrant parents
the Republicans all talk about building
walls and deportations and making people
learn English and then John Kasich my
grandmother was an immigrant who could
barely speak English Ted Cruz my father
was an immigrant from Cuba who didn't
speak English marco rubio my parents
arrived with no money barely speaking
english and of course donald trump my
father was no ranga tang from borneo
it's pretty funny how Cruz and Rubio can
wax nostalgic about their dishwasher
father and hotel maid mom and in the
next breath tell you who they want to
kick out of the country maids and
dishwashers and I must say this puzzles
me because while Republicans generally
do lack the empathy gene that is the
ability to see other people suffer and
then make the complicated leap to I
wonder if that hurts there is an
exception to this they do often get on
the humane side of an issue when it hits
them right in their own home
for example Dick Cheney is so
conservative he got an artificial heart
just to make sure he never felt sorry
for anyone
but he's a big supporter of gay marriage
because he has a gay daughter and he
needs to stay on her good side in case
he needs a kidney
likewise Jeb Bush has been very
compassionate about Mexican immigrants
because he married one one of the good
ones I'm sure
Jeb also had a fairly enlightened drug
policy because his daughter had a
serious problem with cocaine although on
the bright side at least someone in that
family is high energy but that is the
pattern Jeb is a lockstep conservative
but enlightened on Mexicans because of
the wife and cool about drugs because of
the daughter and of course a strong
supporter of special needs education
because of his brother
Oh or take the abortion issue dan quayle
was 100% pro-life and then he was asked
what he would do if his own daughter got
pregnant and he said quote I would
counsel her and talk to her and support
her on whatever decisions you made oh I
see your daughter gets a choice unwanted
children are for strangers
you know Lady Gaga sang a song at the
Oscar Sunday called till it happens to
you it's like that it has to happen to
them it explains why John McCain
supports every form of war ever invented
and some he just fantasizes about in the
shower but torture no because he was
tortured by Sarah Palin
it explains why Ronald Reagan suddenly
cared about AIDS only after it struck
his friend Rock Hudson and why Nancy
Reagan got religion on stem-cell
research
after Ronnie got Alzheimers and it
explains why Newt Gingrich gave up
hunting after he married an owl
on so many issues you can only get
Republican support if it touched one of
their own which is not good news for the
environment I've heard the question many
times when will Republicans stop denying
climate change I'll tell you when when
one of them can be convinced they
personally suffered from it and if the
gods of irony are listening please make
this happen the oceans are dying and all
the fish in them are disappearing
which is why starving sharks swim closer
to the shore now and bite more people
and I'm sorry but one of those people
has to be chris Christie
let him lose one of the arms he uses to
shovel food into his mouth and maybe he
will realize we should do something
about our dying oceans John Kasich wants
a moratorium on all regulations okay but
then please let there be some kind of
mix-up with the pipes and the only water
John Kasich gets to drink from now on is
from Flint Michigan
let James Inhofe be mauled by a
disoriented polar bear let Rush Limbaugh
get attacked by a swarm of dying bees
and the Koch brothers be swallowed up by
a fracking induced earthquake and to
slap the global warming denial at a
Marco Rubio who's own state of Florida
is one of the most likely places to be
inundated by rising oceans his own home
must get flooded and Marco must be swept
out to sea and washed up all the way
back to Cuba where we will find out that
Marco Rubio really is
Elian Gonzalez